hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar the need for
sensitivity the Saito flex family and
new capabilities I am Judy I work of lab
roots and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab routes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by Beckman
Coulter life sciences Beckman Coulter
life sciences develops manufactures and
markets products that simplify automate
and innovate complex pharmaceutical
quality control testing more than
275,000 Beckman Coulter systems operate
in both diagnostics and life sciences
laboratories on seven continents for
over 75 years our products have been
making a difference in people's lives by
improving compliance and reducing costs
of ownership to learn more about Beckman
culture life sciences please visit
www.cannainsider.com/careers Crean label
to ask a question and click on the send
button questions will be answered after
the presentation to enlarge the slide
window click on the arrows at the top
right hand corner of the presentation
window and if you experience technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by typing it into the answer
question box located on the far left of
your screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process of
obtaining your credits I now present
today's speakers peter o'toole PhD and
karen Hogg PhD dr. o Toole serves as
director of the bioscience to
a facility at the University of York as
head of imaging and cytometry labs and
as vice president of the royal
microscopical Society
he gained a PhD in the cell bio Physics
Laboratory at Essex and has been
involved in many aspects of fluorescence
imaging and cytometry dr. o tools
research has focused on both technology
and method development of novel probes
and imaging modalities his lab provides
research support to many academics and
commercial organizations and he has
ongoing collaborations and consultancy
contracts with many leading microscopy
and cytometry companies dr. O'Toole's
complete bio is found on the lab routes
website
dr. Hogg is an experimental officer for
imaging and cytometry at the University
of York's bioscience technology facility
she underpins the scientific service
within the imaging and cytometry
laboratory and takes a lead role in the
research operation and Method
development of cell sorting and analysis
dr. Hogg's expertise is tapped for a
wide range of diverse applications both
within and external to the Department of
Biology dr. Hogg obtained a PhD from the
school of biology at the University of
Leeds in the UK and she received the
Royal microscopical Society medal for
flow cytometry in 2016
her complete bio is also found on the
lab Rhodes website the speakers will now
begin their presentations
Hey Judy thank you very much for those
very kind words yeah
Carol myself at the indeed very well
actually it's a microscopical it's not
the easiest word in the world to say
okay so yeah thank you for inviting us
to talk and I hope you'll enjoy the next
fifty or so minutes of the presentation
itself so actually been invited today to
talk about the size of LEDs and actually
we're based in the multi discipline
department if you haven't seen the
webinar on the astronauts we will just
introduce ourselves in a bit more detail
so I'm Peter and I'm Karen
okay so and we work together on the
place like tomatillos along with Graham
and Karen and Joe also here in imaging a
Scientology facility so actually just a
little bit about us just again we start
it's actually when you're part of a
central facility but also have a
research lab as well so the R&D side but
it's a central facility and the type of
applications that we use that I'd like
to talk about today in more detail so we
are part of a multi-discipline
department of biology so you have a
whole branch branch to my music
there you go we go out of ecology
evolutionists in that plant biologist
that's probably got that's why we've got
a branch branches bass doesn't matter
we'll get to the root of it eventually
so we have a whole breadth of different
users I think I wasn't really buggers
and we'll be talking about the back to
your microbiology samples native are
you've got the really infectious once
they're having the immunologists and so
forth we still got those are still
learning there'd be the developmental
biologists I've got a pun for all I'll
cut it short otherwise this could go on
all day but the bioscience technology
facility itself is made up of the
technology facility is imaging a
cytometry genomics bioinformatics
protein production it's how going to
co-ceo intermolecular interactions a
whole breadth of different technologies
and we have to serve not only that
broadchurch
of internal users but other academic
departments on cameras on campus such as
our chemists and physicists see actually
in bio archaeologists and so forth but
we are also an open access facility so
we take work in from all sorts of other
academic Institute's government bodies
through to commercial companies both
nationally and internationally large and
small and very importantly as we run a
lot of short courses from two-day to
five-day you spoke to ones that are
pre-designed and people just subscribe
into for those courses a lot of those
actually they use the side effects as
well as pass those courses and we do
float ones every January every June and
we do one for the world microscopical
Society it is a hard word isn't it in
September as well so as I've said a long
we are part of a larger bioscience
technology facility we've fit into a
whole curve boards of different
technologies but imaging a cytometry I
would argue is still the number one but
then I guess we are
we are definitely biased and I could
talk you through about how great your
name exceeds how great proteomics is how
wonderful as a biochemist from training
to biochemical analysis but their
community reactions are and actually if
you go to the Astra's talk you'll also
hear me tell you why they are not so
great in some applications but
ultimately microscopy is great because
actually we can look now
in fact genes have been up regulated
down regulated because it produces the
protein we can see that protein is
actually correctly bonded is actually
functional we can look into enzymatic
activities we can do a fret black
flip-flapping flim and lots of other
poor letter F word techniques doing
microscopy but microscopy isn't perfect
either
and that's when flow cytometry comes in
so flow cytometry a picture can say a
thousand words we place on Tom tree can
give us a million data points and make
it statistically relevant I'm really
tall I'm actually going to start talking
today a bit about microscopy it'll make
us think about the importance of
resolution the importance of sensitivity
on what we're doing to our sample and
then you'll understand why some of the
developments that we're seeing in the
new site Thomas is on the market
especially with the APD's with a side
plate and how it can help us bridge that
gap and really get better science and to
our own samples so our lab starts in
2002 can you join me in 2003
ok so that was 15 years ago
and Counting we were quite a small lab
at the time but we've grown into a much
larger facility and now have a whole
team behind us and you can see in the
flow cytometry section that's also
certainly growing so the lab we split
into a serving side and an R&D side of
the map and actually I'm going to give
you a little taste of just one of the
R&D projects now this is cytometry
Saitama trees are measuring themselves
but we're not looking at play site on
between the first instance we're going
to give you where microscopy is today
some of very latest developments from
that will show you how sorry Tommy trees
really needed on the back of that and
where we're using the flow cytometry to
draw applications so much the first one
is actually seeing the invisible and
that's what we do whenever we label a
sample it's it's labeling the sample so
we can see things we would not otherwise
be able to see but in this case I want
to do without labeling so this is maple
free microscopy I'm not talking phase
contrast differential interference
contrast I'm talking about quantitative
phase imaging using a technique called
typography which is even more difficult
to spell than microscopic or now the
important thing here it's labeled
Freitas minimum perturbations so we
don't have to make on the sample that
afternoon what my bread and butter our
service is all about labeling samples
but I would argue that we can eat and
drink and what Karen knows what's coming
we can eat and drink and walk and walk
but naturally as humans we usually
labeled so if you see Karen and myself
right now we are wearing clothes
we are labeled but we can eat and drink
and walk and talk if we were unlabeled I
cover up can okay you need to be careful
when don't don't look too hard don't
look too hard don't think about you
actually are that's even worse think
about it the key part of this aspect is
we can still eat and drink a walking
tour but our subtle behaviors might be
different we might not be static or
casually
we may be a bit more different in our
natural behavior so by minimizing our
need to label the samples we can see the
more natural behavior of the stands and
when we do have to label them the fewer
the labels we have to put on to get the
information the better it will be
hence by minimizing increasing the
sensitivity of our instruments decreases
our need to label them so heavily can
cause fewer plants patients so for
typography this is a pretty classic as a
bright field type of image down your
legs go well typography enables its name
or free without labeling is to convert
this type of image into a quantity
today's image which is gives us much
higher contrast and the intensity of
b-cells
relates to the mass and the volume of
these cells so we're actually getting
statistical we actually am measuring we
have a metric a morphological
information about the cell a
psychometric measurements now the nice
thing about this because you have high
contrast from an imaging side we can now
look at people feels a few so now we've
started to get statistical relevance
just like Glenn cytometry we can track
Lee says I'll skip this slide actually
this one shows it slightly nicer we can
look at our mitosis to to our g1 through
to end of g2 through to mitosis again
but the game I'm looking at the mass of
the cell as the sound goes to cell cycle
it doubles in mass and we can see that
mass increase over time so this is what
it's enabling us to do with that
actually having to use competing my idol
Hearst or daddy or brdu for example but
really the theses are big take home this
is what flow cytometry is do all the
time and then throw away a lot of that
information ok kids actually a flow
cytometry looks at individual cells and
yet quite often we analyze it as the
population and so I'd like to just show
a couple of movies in a minute to
explain that so first off on the right
hand side you go to the next slide this
one here looking this is now a big field
of view about priming hippocampal cells
this is a workpiece and each other
Marcos and Rakesh the mammal and this in
a minute will show you a movie of this
and I'd like to pay attention so I'll
talk you through it as it goes
so actually you find playing the first
movie now look a whole big field of view
then we can look at what we do now
Youssou means just now using the red box
to highlight what we're looking at in
the top left is in microglial cell in
the middle is a cell on a bit of debris
that's gonna get brighter and brighter
and brighter
put it up optic and just the left of
that isn't dead cell we're now going to
see that bright cell pop lose the
intensity in the cell at the top can
scoot down and eat that
sell off that bits of debris soon as
it's done that it will notice his helmet
was at nine o'clock and it's going to
eat that in entirety to come a very
large cell indeed ah that boy that's
there now the yellow bot is what we'll
come to next so you've just seen the red
box and you notice a yellow box just
came up on the screen as well and want
you to look in that yellow box because
just below the center slightly to the
right the cell is about to divide as
soon as a movie starts and so watch that
and these two cells have very different
characteristics so if you play the movie
now look at the yellow box is a cell
just below the center is abouts divided
into two we now have two identical cells
to sell on the Left gets the munchies
it's the hungry sister and all shoot off
starting to eat every bit of apoptotic
material it can see system on the right
just below the air bubble is doing
nothing sit on there shoots off to the
left again and go through they need to
be even more debris just off screen
comes back and there's a lot more to the
north to it shoot off to the north
eating even more now this sound below
appears to have done nothing but he has
it's been getting bigger and bigger and
bigger
up until the point that it divides again
itself and then you have the same will
happen again okay so they have very
different characteristics
now we gave this cell and the hungry
sister that went off to the left and
went up eating actually we gave that
cell a name and we called it Dyson
now I absolutely love this because Dyson
is an example of British engineering we
do something useful okay actually I took
this to America once and did that
actually lazy noise okay Britt
I took it to Germany and they just
thought it was ironic I know she's
brilliant reactions all over but anyway
everyone seems to know who died cities
know the reason we like to include Dyson
is easy elegant and yet simple its
efficient in quiet I cheated if you have
a Dyson actually it isn't so quiet it
really good marketing though huh okay
and it is a world
and of course Dyson is a vacuum cleaner
and that cell was like a vacuum cleaner
and just literally cleaned up everywhere
that went went before it but it's still
a vacuum cleaner but I would like to
point out right now there's more vacuum
cleaners in the world than Saitama ters
so hey go us Brits anyway so what I'd
like to do next is take you I don't this
is a saying same from the same movie in
total and you're gonna be looking at
this area you can see on screen now and
Dyson is going to come in from the right
hand side and clean it up so if we play
the movie no coming from the right clean
up the up top material and disappear off
if you look closely at the new right if
you've got the resolution on your
monitors you can see cleanly off the new
right take it up and go down if you look
at the bottom you'll see a new right
that's about to divide you'll see the
chromosomes align and divide over time
it's pretty cool Dyson is awesome isn't
it I said that that's it's just
incredible you can actually see bits of
a cantata material go inside the
self-weight vanish dot which was
incredible and but what's really cool
about this is we can do this over huge
fields of view and then you can track
cells so you can identify fast cells
slow cells non-moving cells and so forth
so we can do loss about to skip this one
sorry I shouldn't get that in that's my
fault but that's when we found another
cell this one wasn't called Dyson this
for me called Usain Bolt who's arguably
he is also a well leader but being
cunning at this point we're gonna give
him drugs drugs not to speed him up but
to slow him down
so actually got all these cells and
we're gonna give him a drug to actually
slow the cells down cause with
scientists so we're gonna put them in a
control sample that is not very teed so
all the cells are drug treated should be
slower but the fastest cell we ever
record it was as you could guess at
Usain Bolt and drug it doesn't matter
you still doesn't win so you
disqualified for drug cheating at this
point
huh can't lose and so we can get all
these different tracks only individuals
and yet this is from our publication we
showed it as an average population so
it's again back to taking individual
cell analysis but looking at it as a
population and you can see the magenta
with the triangles that the drug the
drug treated are all slower compared to
the control samples with square boxes on
the left but if you notice very
carefully if you go to the seven to two
hours the very top right of that plot
has a magenta triangle Usain Bolt the
fastest cell BarNone way out there even
after 24 to 48 hours he's the fastest
cell in case if we have an outliner for
actually is it an outlier these deities
of drug control cells some cells will
respond differently and in this case we
have one that is either resistant or
responds in the negative way the way we
would not want it now if this was a
cancer cell only three and chemotherapy
at this this is the Salman Ebates of
tried the drugs really a fancy book it
slows all the cell's down brilliance
he's going to control your cancer but
it's that one cell that will end up
killing you how about just call Usain
Bolt a murderer well if it doesn't get
done for drug cheating or getting done
for something else anyway and so this is
really important we need to understand
these cells in much greater detail why
was it an outlier well now we've got all
these are the measurements all these
psychometric measurement was he bigger
Monty skinnier was he more round did he
have a heavier mass we can look at the
mass using this technique so does he
pack more protein and we can use
typography to measure all these but how
often would flow cytometry do we
actually start to break down all that
fine detailed information and this is
where the new approach to flow cytometry
potential analyses are coming in it's a
ton clusters we don't just use our
region's we're now starting to find out
if it's the one that's got more protein
it's actually a smaller cell which is
kind of counter to what you might think
the center that's got more granular
to politicize cancer so by looking at
the movies we can see why we should be
looking at Bogatyr
in greater detail but of course
sometimes we need to see more I can't
tell you how many of any specific
protein any of those cells had which is
why we need to have fluorescence because
that gives us a lot more information now
of course we can correlate microscopy
images with fluorescence so we can take
out type graphic image and we can
overlay it with a pure essence image but
I have no idea how much protein really
is any one of those cells not in any
confidence manner so when I want to look
at the population breast of the
individual I now need to go to my
clothes IO meter now becomes even more
important and I would say now thanks to
be suspects LX and the systems the
sensitivities enabling gets do stuff
that we could not do before so let's
just interesting sites flex s stroke
Alex I would argue this is now an
example of not British engineering
unfortunately but Chinese striking USA
engineering elegant in yet soon but if
you've seen it I'll show you a picture
in a minute it looks very simple it's
efficient and small in this case okay
but it is still I would argue a well
leader but he's only a flow cytometer
remember there's more vacuum cleaners
then there are place item eaters okay so
what's great what really rates the
Avalanche coated eyes new detectors in
there make a world of difference no that
is giving us more lasers more colors
compared to you know the Saitama ters
that we've historically had but it's the
technology the new technology the short
light pass the new detector erasers made
a fundamental difference compared to
what we've been able to do before and so
this is the cycle excess on the less
than the side flex LS it's a big sister
do you know what this reminds me of cars
you know the small minis and the big
minis or the small Fiat and the big
fears yeah I just love the fact that
they're so similar between kind of maxed
it out I still prefer the look of the
small thing sometimes
and so using quantitative measurements
already on our flow cytometry we can use
our size and granularity and
differentiate from our red blood cells
through to our platelets through to our
granular sides
RTB cells etc but we just look at our T
and B cells and lymphocytes we can't
actually differentiate between them
because they're pretty much the same
sizing granularity other so so we can't
so we now need to start using
fluorescence in more detail and we can
use those markers marking membranes and
so forth and actually if we looked at
them on the microscope you can see
there's not really much difference
between these three cells thank you very
little contrast difference the cells are
there I've just put some arrows on there
so you can see the cells without any
fluorescence yeah this microscope wasn't
the best in the world means once they're
fixed it's difficult to see but if I
label them I can now see the cells at
the more detail I can now look at the
amount of DNA up and see where they are
a cell cycle we can add our antibody
stains and we can start to look at the
sides getting the proteins tubulin
they're affected we could look at
mitochondria over the microscope we
cannot readily quantify the amount of
protein in any of these instances or the
amount of DNA or the amount of ice
conduit can be done but it's not easy
and flow cytometry does this with ease
and so here we have actually a really
nice example of quantifying the amount
of proteins per cell and in this case
you can see for these cells on our
bridge there was 55 thousand proteins
per cell and that's what we would
publish 55,000 proteins per cell but
just as we saw earlier okay
there's variability here so we have a
broad distribution we have some cells
that have 500,000 proteins on the cell
surface and we have others 30 10,000
that's a huge difference that's a bit
like saying all humans are a monoculture
with alma say and yet if you look at the
hair
that's our proteins maybe on a cell
surface some of us have a lot more hair
than others unfortunately don't look at
the back have not quite so much chance
thank goodness the bed camp only looks
this way and not that way I'm sure me a
lot worse and so I've never looked I
don't know I don't want to know so we
need to embrace these hips Jenaya t even
within mono Compson start to understand
what it means okay so for those ten ten
thousand five hundred thousand this is
where resolution really counts because
we don't want to know broadly when these
have got a few these have got a lot we
now need to get down to be aunty
Katniss to resolve this in much greater
detail this is where the size of place
really comes into its own and because
resolution matters I've got one more
illustration this is a picture of me and
Cameron and a few others not great
because we've got six pick stars anyone
gets this when we look at images and if
we increase the people cells we start to
see more information there carries I
think on the right I think he might be
the one that makes the Cameron again
well we almost next to each other hey at
least he's actually us and that's that
if you still meet device but if you
improve the resolution still you can now
start to count the number of hair
follicles on our hair
thank you for in the dreaming it's
rather nice of course after the drink
things tend to go backwards and we start
to lose resolution again but that's why
resolution so importance and play
cytometry but after look at the staining
in depth by resolution why is this
important give you a nice example now
actually can't talk through this one
it's about yes contact okay so this is
an example looking at a bead mix
population from gerhart and we looked at
it on the site blacks using the 405
nanometers eleiza and for side scatter
and the four eight eight nanometer laser
their side scatter as well and closer
together the peaks are in the wavelength
stands trees and the better resolution
you'll be able to to see on the site
ometer and you can see that the
populations really pull out much
Clara when we use the 405 nanometer
laser for side scatter as our trigger
compared to the compared to the 488 and
the boxes are more clearly resolved and
those gracious spaces between those bead
crowds that you can see on the screen so
the first plot on the left hand side has
better separation of those compared to
the middle plot and so that's what that
increased resolution gives you when you
use a different wavelength laser to
trigger on the cytometer so this is a
keep we showed you earlier Usain Bolt
that outlier now if you look I just have
fuzzy displays I told me two x's is that
an outlier or is that just instrument
noise detector noise we don't got no
confidence well as a resolution tightens
up in our populations tighten up
certainly those outliers will be
revealed and they're genuine outliers
not just instrument ones so really nice
illustration of how that affects it so
actually a classic test now is just use
eight peak beads so can anyone talk to
the end piece yeah so traditionally when
we get play Saitama to have a look at
we've all put eight pink beads and that
means you've got eight different peaks
of fluorescence on the flow cytometer
pots and they're shown there on the on
the screen and we've got three different
cytolytic one in red one in blue and one
in one in light blue they're not
literally that color we don't actually
paint our Saitama ters you know just the
visual representation of it and the site
flex is shown in the top in the red
Peaks and then we've got two other flow
cytometer x' or comparison and you can
see quite clearly that the resolution in
the piece is much better within the site
flags than in the other two site amitis
of this is using the four eight eight
laser and looking at the the fitzy
channel so that's in a greenish area and
the data is shown here graphically and
you can see that the site flex is shown
in blue and you've got a much better
staining index compared to the other
instruments between those first two
peaks
as if you just go back well that's just
looking at the first two piece and the
resolution between them and that shows
here the standing bits is much better as
we went to higher intensities for the
difference yes there was but but not
sometimes a mate so dis down in the doom
end that we saw a better including with
the cytoplasm led to the other 2% images
that we were looking at but that was
with the 488 laser so we wants to see
how the other lasers as well and then
that's comparing across the Greens that
lose the red channels of the lasers as
well so this is really telling because
now you've gone to before I tank you
were going to fire red and a PDS having
much better sensitivity better quantum
efficiency out in the red compared to
normal photomultiplier tubes okay so the
reason why there's only two plots in
here in case the observant and you have
noticed is that one of the first items
didn't have a far red channel with the
488 laser so this is looking at far
right of the 488 laser and again the
site flex is shown in the red Peaks and
you can clearly see the resolution is
much better compared to the blue Peaks
which is shown them in the until center
of the center of the screen and the
graphical data as well which i think is
shown on the next slide oh no first of
all got some arrows just to really
clearly point that out to you where the
better resolution is is quite visual and
then so how would you resolve that if
you look at extension how to actually
resolve that and knowing where to even
draw your staining Dixon this is where
resolutions only we can see that opulent
clearly oh I think there's some slides
later on that's using some dot plot so
what we'll come to that so this is now
moving on to the red laser so this is
looking at the third the red shifted
part of the spectrum this is where the
LPGs really do show improve resolution
you can see much clearer separation
between between the peaks so you've got
more distance to see data from and when
you go a little bit further red again so
we're talking sorts of 700 750 in the
wavelength spectrum you can see the
peaks are clearly resolved in there in
the red Peaks show than the slight place
whereas on the other
Lu Peaks they're sort of merging in
together you'd have more difficulty in
discerning the data and that ones so
this is great this is on eight peak
beats it's actually this is really
relevant when you start to look at low
expresses so no expression of proteins
in different cell types dim Bing not you
and it wasn't calling you Dan or promise
almost speechless but that that would be
too much to tell speechless so this is a
really nice example of how this can
benefit so if we look at the top
histogram you'll see that if you've got
a positive to the right under that are
three region you've got a nice positive
population and to the left you've
actually got a double population so
they've got autofluorescence of two
different populations but you can still
identify the percentage of unlabeled
cells as you come down we can still see
that but it's harder to drop your marker
region down so now I'm going to use a
double dot blot is much better where
resolving there's positives with
negatives and as if you look at the
bottom one if you can I get the
positives a lot of those are hiding that
second high wall tone for S&P so there'd
be no counts as positives if you weren't
wise to this we push it even further if
you look at the top graph there's only
two piece we've lost that third peak
whereas now we can still resolve those
auto caresses for the weekly stained
ones so she spoke we can do this anyway
yeah now we've lost it it's into the
noise and a lot of that noise it's
instrument noise itself because a
resolution and the sensitivity of the
instrument but we've already shown you a
very similar scenario so if you look at
the blue population here you can see
that this is very similar to what we
just seeing above and yet if we now
overlay that with improved resolution we
can now resolve those two bits really
nicely this is actually a pain if I'm
honest we do a flow cytometry course and
we teach how to pull out weak signals
and now we have to use a dilution that
is even more dilute until you can no
longer resolve it because it just
resolves in the side-effects which would
never easy
in any other site amitis before so
resolution quantification is really
important to us and now we want to do
quantification
so Cameron you want to talk to the
homies Ian okay so this is some what we
did with them you and Minter and Mike
broadcast and they wants to look at
Paramecium and Paramecium is is quite a
large beast and we've got some pictures
later and they have symbionts inside
them they have the algae inside them to
do some work for giving them some some
energy and they wants to quantify the
number of algae within within the
Paramecium and so in these plots here
we've got the bacteria in the culture
now that's not there because we were -
we couldn't keep our culture's clean
that was there because because the
Paramecium also do eat the bacteria as
well so they're they're there as a food
source but they also want the algae to
help them go to synthesize light energy
to sugars so wanted to see how over
different light levels the Paramecium
managed their algae do they have more
algae when there's low light levels to
do more work and when there's high light
intensity so they kick them out because
they don't need so many workers because
there's more light available so this was
the scenario that came to us with and so
what we wanted to do was have a look at
the best way of achieving this and so we
had how decide to flex on site of this
at this time and we wanted to compare
that to our existing flow cytometer but
the existing flow cytometer
only enabled us to look at log height
data and so we wanted to see about
staining index as to how much
improvement the site is less we had and
we can see here with the staining index
calculations shown here that we've gone
much greater separation between the
algae and Paramecium in the site flex
compared to the other place our
temperatures so we can see a clear
benefit on the left hand plot compared
to this for the other flights 800 meters
shown on the right and also to note is
the scaling now on the site next we have
seven long decades have a really big
dynamic range which is great because you
can fit everything on scale so nothing
needs to be missed which is clearly
what's occurring on there and the other
place is we can resolve the bacteria
over the noise yes much more cleanly
which what about ours is showing me
essentially
when I rose that sounds I see you know
we think about it pretty sure we have
the red arrow is about bishops plate
formation why don't you read Advent just
confusing so so that's a so that was
good so we could we could we could see a
benefit with middle side effects but
this was using log height but we can
also look at area so we can look at the
total thrust intensity I can't benign
eyes are important well the the peak
will only tell you their height and a to
the maximum signal of thrusts but for
each sample whereas the area will tell
you that the total the integrated signal
above the threshold values which gives
you much more idea of the presence
that's actually inside the cells I think
picture to go down through these prove
it well there's a challenge
well I said I'll show you a picture the
Paramecium with the algae inside so all
those little balls inside are the number
volume and we can try and count these so
we've got a visual
you know quantification so we know what
number wearing out so let's try 1 2 3 4
5 6 17 18 no he's gonna confuse me now
so we've done some of this already so
then you know maybe 10 or 20 and we
could keep going with this bags girls
are to what roughly 200 entries about
and we've done some taking the confocal
Zed slices you can get the whole ball
you can physically can then which is
pretty cumbersome to work out how many
of the world would get it so we wanted a
better way of doing it and we thought
using their area on the flow cytometer
would enable you to do that and this
gives you a nice diagram as to what the
log height and the log area is actually
representing and so the blue shows you
the total signal within within the
within the within the Paramecium so
if we could ratio then the free algae to
that let's in the Paramecium itself we
would get an idea as to the actual
number of algae within each Paramecium
and if you do that with the height
values we came out about 44 which was
clearly not correct but when we did this
with microscopy comparisons we could see
that we had a very good estimation of
the number of algae in the Paramecium
using the the area values so this game
is psychometric quantification and again
this is by that resolution really
matters and tightens it up otherwise
we've got much bigger variance on that
183 so we won that because you want to
see the ones I've got more or less not
just dividing instrument oice and
finally as you've more or less things to
put noise at that time okay so so that
was one example of quantification using
those items and we're resolution really
counts to get to get the data but going
to some different example now we're
looking at some estimation of plant
genome size and so again we're going to
see Peaks and we need to be able to see
what is what no and it's always an
interesting start to your day when
somebody arrives with the sample that
looks like this and that ham can't quite
put that through the flow cytometer in
its initial form so there we've gotta
they've got poppy we've got maize we've
got Sawyer and a few other plants that I
can't quite gentle back to my plum not
our Forte so how do we actually get it
into a flow cytometer
it's a quick process it is useful it's
through this fine so so we can get our
plant tissue we can chop it in
hypertonic lysis buffer and then we can
add P I and it goes red in the tube not
outside the tube that's shown there but
we won't worry about that we also do
filter it to make sure that we don't
lock a flow cytometer
and then onto the instrument it goes and
that takes about 40 minutes with a 30
minute incubation time so it so it's a
pretty quick process and so here we have
our leaf tissue that has been stained
with a DNA binding bag which is
propidium iodide and we're using a
trigger pure essence trigger so that we
get rid
a lot of a lot of the debris within our
sample but you can see the middle plot
shows that we still have got a bit of a
mess in terms of are scattered branches
but we can use the fluorescence to
identify the stains nuclei within the
sample which is what's shown in red so
we can get on the nuclei and then take
it further forward to look for analysis
now when we do genome estimation we use
standards that we obtain from a standard
seed bank and we can contain peaks of
DNA content from a from a known species
now in this experiment we were looking
for the genome size of poppy which was
unknown we were comparing it to the
three plant species that are listed to
further down so we've got radish a
tomato and then a maize and then we were
able to do this in log on the site flex
but log isn't great for looking for G 1
2 G 2 Peaks but because I'm looking for
such a large range of standards I wanted
to be able to see all of the data on the
same settings and on our other first
items have had to use on a log scale to
be able to visualize it but I wanted to
test this and this was work that was
done fairly recently to put it on the
flow cytometer and see over the dynamic
range that I wanted to use could I see
it all in Lunia on the site flex and I
could and that's a real benefit for the
large dynamic range within the site
place because now I can see those g1 and
g2 Peaks quite clearly but I've got the
data involve ambulinia so I've got
choices here which is great best of both
worlds so then what we do is we use the
equation that's shown in the top from
the standards because they have an own
DNA to see pika brand value and you can
ratio the presence intensities from your
unknown to the standards and get on
future brands with DNA values out and
these can then be turned into mega base
pairs but the gene and sites you have to
remember if it's difficult or happened
to be able to do the conversion to base
pairs but that was and that was good and
you can clearly see how resolution and
sensitivity the gaining of Peaks and
clarity is really
important so so that was so that was
that and now we've quickly something so
we are giving you examples of extreme
like the courses we always choose
examples of best exemplified features of
the flow cytometry we went to Australia
phenotyping samples as you there pretty
routine and we can get taking the
extreme scenarios it can really benefit
but some of these samples properties so
demanding to get the best out the site
on sit there the best illustrate and
what can be done with it so this is a
system might be in tonight's that you
didn't store one so I'm already thinking
about my drinks can we go on go Chris so
this one this is work then at Chris
McDonald's lab and hey has a huge panel
of yeast protease samples it wants to
look at let's see the green fluorescent
protein their GFP and their M sherry
content and so this uses the 96 file
format of the site black so you can use
it in tube or plate mode but this is
definitely one where we want to do Zin
plate mode because you could set it up
and then fresco and then walk away so
that was a big attraction here so that
was a you know taken as a good sign
floor so we've got in the first plot
we've got a Ford inside this gutter and
this is yeast and you can see we're
using the log Fordham science cutter for
this parameter so that we can really be
able to see all of the population and
quite nicely and the yeast are about 6 5
microns pre-job smaller than our typical
mammalian cells and the next plot along
we've got forward scatter against an
autofluorescence marker for dead cells
and so that's what the black 5 days and
then moving on further through we can
see our GFP on the y-axis and I labeled
them green so that we can populate that
because the GFP you've got very low
expression is just fundamental always
know expressions were a lot of
expression I presume yes it's biological
variation teeny one throughout it wasn't
expecting all bright or dim variation so
that was our set up shown in those top
three plots and then lower down I
haven't shown you all 96 some
so we ran in this sum this I'll say I've
just picked out one GFP so you can see
the background associated with with the
I'm sherry and I think I've got a point
zero six percent background marker there
we go it's just a diffuse cloud isn't it
and then we can clearly see in the the
McGee's sample that was expressing gfp
and cherry we've got a cloud coming up
and it was particularly interested in
quantifying or getting the percentage of
gfp and m cherry double positive which
you can see there and then it towards
the end i've just used the software
that's available on the site reflects to
easily produce an over like to show you
the damn cherry expression in the GFP
only and then the GFP and M charming
salt so it looks like most of expression
M cherry to a greater or lesser degree
Lots here and under the send of you want
ever essence just not in the variability
so zooming Allah sees your fingers
zooming I do like that I presume Inge
and the panning panning doesn't quite
show so well on the video so as I've
gone for zooming so often on their on
their place lights vomit on the sites
place you know we've done the QC and
we've got the settings that best for the
day and we don't really want to change
them so we run the sample and then it
all looks down in the bottom corner but
we can zoom in we can change the axis on
on the site pets this is just showing
you what the sample is and this is the
yeast again but when we zoom and this
isn't changing the gains this is just
changing the display and you can clearly
change the display so you can see your
data so it doesn't matter if it's all in
the bottom corner initially we can zoom
or we can pan to visualize it and we can
still use those perfect optimized
settings that the quality control checks
have given us so she's great Ezeli
animal to use a facility not everyone
stats and flow cytometry up as you may
want it to be whereas now you can go as
down with our experiment because
everything's kind of fixed it makes so
life so much easier users not too
worried about it and we can go in and
actually go and see what's really going
on afterwards and save their experiment
so I think now I don't need to divide or
not invited she's got more puns and I
have today
this is getting embarrassing so what's
really nice now is obviously we've got
405 nanometers much most I'm sending all
that out on us and most of you will have
a four-way by but you know I thought
we'd seen the back of you V's there's
new dyes coming together need though
juvies and actually go into the me UV @
v p UV makes a big difference to some of
the sample so in this case the 375 and
if we look at the difference this makes
again the resolutions all about
resolution because if we now got a 3.75
we can excite Dappy better which means
we get better emission profile better
signal-to-noise that sustaining index so
we can now resolve our g2 s and G ones
and S phase is much better than we could
before
so 375 is giving us that advantage as
you can see here who such as that we
also have the five six one laser as well
as a four eight eight nine and again
many of us not all of us have the five
six one laser but that does a similar
thing again we can now use it for cell
cycle and actually if you listen to the
Astra's talk we talked about using
different parasites this one's a nice
example of leishmaniasis and again we
want to pull out the sound cycle on this
which is not so easy but again we've got
a much better pull out Betty series
using the five six one laser compared to
the borate nanometer laser which is this
is showing you at the moment
and now we really go far out dude and
this is now going right answer 808
nanometers anyone has ever watched
lazytown you took me ages to work this
out lazy Turner
Sportacus he's bedtime he's 808 time for
bed and it always goes to bed at 8 to 8
so I guess this is the end as well she's
not quiet house okay I think what can we
do with the far-out laser well there are
now fixable infrared guys okay so we've
got a live date dicing that frees up
that or i'vei've nanometre if you use
Nearpod app you using your P italic
freeze that up because we can now use
alive dead using infrared
like dead stain which you can see here
so it works just as well as it would
have been a Maya died or any of the
other type of Dragon dies and stuff like
that so we've got this and we can use it
alive dead and we can compare
adapted a PR in the Flex infeasible IR
so just shows that we can use it and it
frees the 808 has freed up the other
channels for you more classy florid
Chrome's that are still currently
available but you can also get better
excitation of your alexa 719 tweens we
now have another antibody we can tag
your cell 90 releasing again enabling us
to do more complex color pants as we can
see here and yeah now the 808 is there
and it's coming more reagents will
follow including things like infrared
GFP s out there which would not use much
because no one's we now to do much with
them but now we've got detectors that
can detect red signals PMT's just don't
see anything kept for that eight only
this so insensitive
it is sleep right samples be able to
pick them up this is kind of resolve
that problem and finally very quickly
compensation one other thing that people
come on the courses we teach
compensations to an nth degree and
actually now it's all gang go pain
because our users can't get compensation
well I know they can they can get it
wrong I guess but we can get back and
get it right without having to do any
reruns of their experiments because
there is no voltage and just changing
the game so if you change the game by
two you change the compensation back to
the case it really straightforward
linear process at this point so actually
on this example here we can look at our
compensation if you look at that on the
right hand box we do prove it to change
our game from two three two two three
three two those numbers change without
us doing anything we set it for two
three two we change the voltage it
changed the compensation automatically
which is kind of cool and we can go the
other way two one three two and it
compensating the other one and it's
still worse then only eat now to to
worry about get anything perfect to look
right in the frosting since we can do it
retrospectively so to compare this and
the sensitivity just phone one last
liking which is for the CFS II study now
this is real data this isn't perfect
data this is since one of the samples
would really optimize this is just
real user samples can enjoy sort through
this really quickly so this wisdom and
CFC example as Pete said and this was
done on our hands-on flow course and
this is side-by-side comparison run at
the same time on on two different site
altars and the site reflects nature is
shown in the top engage it on T cells
you can see that the top panel compared
to the one directly below it you've got
more Peaks visually available to see and
to analyze but when you get on the cd4 T
cells again you can choose out more
peaks in the top purple boss compared to
the blue and then it doesn't matter if
you get on the CBA so you've got the
same answer so whether you have all T
cells all the T cd4 on the TCGA subsets
you've got better resolution and this
will give you more robust and better
data points as you go through so it was
just one comparison won't throw a legend
resolution and sensitivity can make it
can make a difference to what you
actually be able to see you know I don't
seem dated better than that type stuff
better than that topsides blacks data on
over the site on so I've seen you
looking better that's because the sample
has been better at that point they said
really nice examples I see plenty of the
below images as well and we can't do
anything the users like Alma you don't
you really go to struggle to do any
analysis with this was actually the size
of Lex again he's now getting this out
which I'm looking imperfect sample in
this case it more on the challenges you
know imagine a really good sample and
how clear those top Pete's would be I'm
going to try this ourselves it's going
to be awesome because we Wow they just
get me so much cleaner
compared to the rest so challenge laid
count for that team so really this is
not just about resolution it's about
getting more information about it and
more colors we would say the greater the
scientific electability
of your system so skip over into our the
great thing is sensitivity meta
quantification more colors it's great we
announce a plate load at last and be
able to do tube mode as well so we can
choose depending on the user they can
use to merge or the music played mode
and this is really good at that point so
flow is really just starting point and
we talked about all those other
technologies at the start and really
once we can see those populations we
need to know more about them once we
know those hi expresses those love
expresses just what the difference is
across those multiplex analyses we can
then go on to the sorters isolate them
and understand more about them but again
if you wanna know about sorting side go
and watch the Ostrogoths webinar so
probably more entertaining than this one
so finally I would say Paris's to our
cytometry because I think we rule the
world if we don't we will uncertain in
science world and so finally thank you
to all our team I see the current team
with Karen Joe in band make and everyone
else and fans focus team for the day -
you saw earlier which I think
illustrating nicely the importance of
sensitivity and resolution and actually
I we can't find how groups enough really
helped us get all this data providing
data and providers reveal challenges day
in there and giving us the satisfaction
seeing their science succeed so well and
actually we've got a small thank you
actually been and cool turning roderick
please app support over the years
thank you very much i think before we
get to questions I think Batman quarter
up just a quick a couple of quick survey
questions for you so I leave you with
those a couple of quick survey questions
for a few seconds thank you dr. O'Toole
and dr. Hogg for your presentations a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button
dr. O'Toole and dr. Hogg will answer as
many questions as time permits and the
first question is how user-friendly is
it it's extremely user friendly on
counts we can't have endures more than
training for users these days than I do
so yeah the users have found it very
easy to pick up on within a short period
of time that they're so
they're able to use it without much
intervention now come in and
troubleshoot when they change the
application slightly but they find the
software very intuitive and it the
system very reliable and easy to use so
no it's been good yeah I agree I'm
changing it's just made changing over to
the side suplex a lot of users found it
a lot easier than they thought they
would compare this to moving from other
different saitama sitting there in the
past there so thank you Judy good
question thank you for that your next
one is how many colors does the Saito
flex s and LX have can I be starting yes
for the LX we're looking at I think 21
colors yes so fluorescence detection I'm
always thinking colors I'm quite
colorful whereas science flex SES 13
colours unlucky for some certainly not
for us
so 13 or 21 colors which is pretty good
I look forward to maybe seeing more in
their futures there's a lot of
flexibility yeah thank you Judy okay
next one is do you use it for standard
immuno phenotype thing yes yes a lot of
the groups do use it pretty much
standard and phenotyping outside we've
got also there's lots of genotyping
assays and they really like the easy
compensation setup or the for the system
because I have all the compensation
libraries set up and it means they can
just bring the few samples they have
down and run them without having to do
all the single color controls every time
which switch they really enjoy and it's
been a big benefit to the amount of
antibodies they've had to use as well as
than that time that's then stay in the
sample and running it on the site ometer
so yeah it's been good yeah I really
didn't show much phenotyping data but we
use these on our flow courses and their
flow courses obviously have a lot
typical phenotyping type data sets in
there really phenotyping can show some
good examples we just wanted to show
something a bit different it was really
pushing the limits of the site on to
more than most classic phenotype
experiments thanks Judy okay your next
one is does it do deep well 96 well
plates yes
I didn't use to in the past yeah but it
comes out great music you know too deep
nine to six one place which is cool okay
have you done evie work with the Seidel
flex so yeah extracellular vesicles yeah
these are quite often a big challenge
Karen so yes we have done we have to
work with EBX sound beads calls them
with this light glass beads we've
stained them so we can use fly students
to be able to see them and I know above
background signals and make sure we you
know filter all the buffers to keep the
background down as low as possible
yes we we've been you know using using
the site place for that application
successfully it's been good yeah now
that's again that's where the resolution
it really comes in if you've got that
resolutions tighten those peace up and
see the signals over the noise you know
that's what it's all about really we
just not been there the party's open
lots of opportunities nothing
yeah thank you Judy okay looks like we
have time for one more question it is
absolute counts can I do that as well
absolutely counting yeah yeah yeah yes
so that this likes places is a pump
driven what's right technology driven so
um you can do absolutely counting with
with that and so you get events per
microliter with your sample data and you
don't have to select it you'd always
counts sample count so you don't have to
think oh no I've got them to request it
you always get it so that's good and you
can check it as well with beads if you
want to and there's a little calculation
within the software so you can also
cross-check it with bead counting as
well and I've I've done that and you
know the answers are very comparable
between the absolute county and the beat
counting which is always reassuring the
semester and iced half proof we trusting
you
Thank You Julie well thank you I would
like to once again thank dr. O'Toole and
dr. Hogg for their presentations do you
have any final comments no because thank
you very much thank you listening go I'm
sorry do you need too much time for
questions at the end
we've got company enthusiastic in places
so might might fall to the early stages
how are we doing we have to take
questions offline as well afterwards
thank you I'd like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions and as he says
doctor hopeful said questions we did not
have time for today will be addressed by
these speakers afterward we would like
to thank our sponsor Beckman Coulter
life sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through December 2018
lab routes will alert you via email and
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye